Que s'est-il donc passé ?
Cayla a été bannie en Allemagne,
retirée des étagères d'Amazon et de Wal-Mart
et elle repose maintenant paisiblement
au musée de l'espionnage de Berlin.
(Rires)
Toutefois, Cayla a été vendue dans des magasins du monde entier
pendant plus d'un an après la publication de notre rapport.
Ce que nous avons découvert, c'est qu'il y a peu de règles protectrices
et que celles que nous avons ne sont pas correctement appliquées.
Ces appareils doivent être sûrs et protéger notre vie privée
avant d'entrer sur le marché :
pourquoi devrait-on verrouiller une maison avec une clef
si tout le monde peut y entrer grâce à un dispositif connecté ?
Vous pourriez vous dire : « Cela ne m'arrivera pas.
Je resterai loin de ces appareils imparfaits. »
Mais cela ne garantira pas votre sécurité
car simplement en utilisant internet,
vous êtes dans une situation cornélienne de type « à prendre ou à laisser ».
Laissez-moi vous montrer.
Comme beaucoup, j'ai des dizaines d'applis sur mon portable
et, utilisées correctement, elles peuvent faciliter notre vie,
la rendre plus pratique et peut-être plus saine.
Mais avons-nous été bercés dans un sentiment de sécurité trompeur ?
Cela commence simplement en cochant une case.
Nous disons oui.
J'ai lu les conditions.
Mais avez-vous vraiment lu les conditions ?
Ne semblaient-elles pas trop longues,
votre téléphone manquait de batterie
et puis, la dernière fois, elles étaient impossibles à comprendre
et vous aviez vite besoin de ce service ?
Et désormais, le déséquilibre de force est établi
car nous avons accepté que nos données personnelles
soient collectées et utilisées à une échelle inimaginable.
Mes collègues et moi avons ainsi décidé d'étudier cela plus profondément.
Nous avons entrepris de lire les conditions d'utilisation
des applis populaires d'un téléphone ordinaire.
Et pour prouver au monde à quel point c'est irréaliste
de s'attendre à ce que les gens lisent véritablement les conditions,
nous les avons imprimées,
cela fait plus de 900 pages,
et nous nous sommes mis au travail pour les lire nous-mêmes à voix haute,
en diffusant l'expérience sur nos sites internet.
Vous pouvez le voir, cela a pris du temps.
Cela nous a pris 31 heures, 49 minutes et 11 secondes
pour lire les conditions d'utilisation d'un téléphone.
C'est plus long qu'un marathon de films de la saga « Harry Potter »
suivie de la trilogie « Le Parrain ».
(Rires)
Et lire est une chose.
Comprendre en est une autre.
Cela nous aurait pris bien, bien plus longtemps.
Et c'est un vrai problème :
les entreprises se sont opposées pendant 20 ou 30 ans
à une meilleure réglementation d'internet
car les utilisateurs ont accepté les conditions d'utilisation.
Et nous l'avons montré avec l'expérience,
accepter en connaissance de cause est presque impossible.
Pensez-vous que c'est juste de faire peser la responsabilité sur le consommateur ?
Moi, non.
Nous devrions demander moins de « à prendre ou à laisser »
et des conditions plus compréhensibles avant de les accepter.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Maintenant, j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire à propos d'amour.
Certaines applis les plus populaires sont des applis de rencontres,
un secteur qui représente maintenant près de trois milliards de dollars par an.
Et bien entendu, nous sommes d'accord pour partager nos détails intimes
avec notre moitié.
Mais qui d'autre fouine,
enregistre et partage nos données
alors que l'on dévoile notre être ?
Mon équipe et moi avons décidé d'enquêter.
Et afin de comprendre le problème sous tous ses angles
et d'effectuer un travail vraiment minutieux,
j'ai réalisé que je devais télécharger
une des applis de rencontres les plus populaires au monde.
Je suis rentré voir ma femme chez moi...
(Rires)
que je venais juste d'épouser.
« C'est bon si je me crée un profil sur une appli de rencontres populaire
uniquement à des fins scientifiques ? »
(Rires)
Voici ce que nous avons trouvé.
Cachée derrière le menu principal, il y avait une case pré-cochée
qui donnait à l'entreprise l'accès à toutes mes photos Facebook personnelles,
dans mon cas plus de 2 000 photos,
dont quelques-unes vraiment personnelles.
Et ce n'est pas le pire ;
quand nous avons lu les conditions,
nous avons découvert cela --
je vais sortir mes lunettes pour lire ceci --
et je vais lire pour vous, car c'est compliqué.
Bien.
« En postant du contenu » --
c'est-à-dire vos photos, vos messages
et autres interactions dans l'appli --
« cela faisant partie du service,
vous donnez automatiquement à l'entreprise,
ses affiliés, ses licenciés et ses successeurs
un droit irrévocable, » -- vous ne pouvez pas changer d'avis --
« perpétuel, » -- soit, pour toujours --
« non exclusif, transmissible, cessible, acquitté
et universel d'utiliser, copier, garder, accéder, afficher
recopier, enregistrer, jouer, adapter, modifier, distribuer,
préparer des travaux dérivés du contenu,
ou incorporer le contenu dans d'autres travaux
et autorisez les droits ci-dessus dans n'importe quel média
déjà connu ou créé a posteriori. »
Cela veut simplement dire que tout votre historique de rencontres
et tout ce qui y est lié peut être utilisé dans n'importe quel but, à vie.
Imaginez simplement vos enfants voir vos photos fougueuses de rencontres
utilisées dans une pub de contraception dans 20 ans.
Mais sérieusement --
(Rires)
que peuvent signifier ces pratiques commerciales ?
Par exemple, une perte financière :
selon votre historique de recherche,
des algorithmes décident si vous pouvez faire un emprunt.
Être manipulé :
les entreprises analysent vos émotions selon vos images et vos messages
et vous ciblent avec des pubs lorsque vous êtes le plus vulnérable.
Être discriminé :
une appli de fitness peut vendre vos infos à une assurance-vie,
ce qui vous empêchera d'être couvert plus tard.
Tout cela est d'actualité dans le monde aujourd'hui.
Bien sûr, les données ne sont pas toujours utilisées nuisiblement.
Certaines sont imparfaites, incomplètes
et d'autres sont très bonnes.
Et il y a aussi de bonnes nouvelles.
Les entreprises de rencontres ont changé leurs politiques
après que nous avons porté plainte.
Mais les organisations comme la mienne,
qui défendent nos droits, ne peuvent pas être partout.
Le consommateur ne peut pas résoudre ça seul non plus,
car s'il sait que quelque chose d'innocent qu'il a dit
peut revenir le hanter,
il ne parlera pas.
Si nous savons que nous sommes observé et espionné,
nous changerons notre comportement.
Si nous ne pouvons contrôler la possession et l'utilisation de nos données,
nous avons perdu le contrôle de notre vie.
Les histoires que j'ai racontées aujourd'hui ne sont pas des cas isolés.
Elles sont partout
et elles sont un signe que les choses doivent changer.
Et comment peut-on effectuer ce changement ?
Les entreprises doivent comprendre
qu'en faisant de la vie privée et de la sécurité des priorités,
elles peuvent bâtir la confiance et la loyauté de leurs clients.
Les gouvernements doivent créer un internet plus sûr
en assurant l'application et l'actualisation des règles.
Et nous, les citoyens ?
Nous pouvons utiliser notre voix
pour rappeler au monde que la technologie ne peut réellement bénéficier à la société
que si elle respecte les droits fondamentaux.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)